uh Kingo it looked like he was giving
you a good scoring boost in the first
half what went into the decision not to
have him play in this yeah he was
playing great and and U you know his
normal time to go back in would have
been around the um you know five six
minute Mark and uh wigs was was playing
great we were rolling we're up 18 19
whatever it was and so we just stayed
with him and then at that point um it
didn't feel you know um like it was the
right thing to do he'd been sitting for
a while so I stayed with the group that
was out there and um obviously um you
know we couldn't couldn't close it out
you you only scor four in the last I
think
634 uh what do you think was the biggest
just offensive problems like what Boggs
you down uh you know we just um we
weren't getting a great penetration um
you know earlier in the game we were
getting a lot of pocket passes um you
know from the perimeter and then playing
kind of four on three three on two and
we didn't get any of those they really
tightened up and um so we we had to take
a lot of contested shots and uh
and just you know they they buckle down
like I said I give them
credit